good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday it is
hump day here in new york i don't know
what day it is elsewhere
but i hope that you all are humping
someone you absolutely love today i for
one will be partaking with my son theo
i'm so happy for you so happy to see
theo here he is looking
splendid just got groomed so he's
smelling like
so delicious i want to like stick my
nose up his butt i'm hitting you with
that
where are you cutest little dude
it's really feeling like a crunchy angel
dora kind of day you think i feel like
that's what we need that's like the
daily affirmation that we need today
in order to get into the spirit of
things five
six seven eight doo doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo theodora theodora
crunchy angel dora beautiful lovey dora
precious mandora longest ears dora
love of my life oh my god
you swerved on me you swerved the [ __ ]
on me
[Laughter]
i'm so hurt and embarrassed we might
have our first
walk off on the show beautiful gems
perfectly
come here i wonder what happened like
you have to watch a backseat but like
what did i do that hurt his feelings i
love you
that was so crazy please come back you
look so cute right now he made a choice
today maybe he wanted
he broke up and chose hurtfulness like
maybe he wanted you to be able to see
him
no i don't know i'm just trying to at
first i thought he was like getting off
the couch because he was like [ __ ]
done with our singing
and then not only did he not it turned
into a disappear he just
turned his back on me completely yeah
and went over to yadanti
whoo that is really hard for i don't
know how i can go on with the show and
do my job when i've just like literally
been slapped in the face with my own
blood
no i know nobody makes me bleed my own
blood and that was supposed to be like
an uplifting
tune it just turned so dark so fast for
you and on hump day of
all days theo wow well we were
trying to tell you something we planned
on having a good show for you guys today
but now i just don't know
i mean for me it's going great happy for
you know that i am
really happy for you i mean
just just ignore him um i'm gonna do my
best i'm so upset and so hurt but let's
move on could be a great show for you
guys today it's wednesday it's hump day
which means we have deer toasters which
i'm super excited about
we should have our real housewives of
dallas recap but i just didn't feel like
watching a subpar franchise especially
given all the drama going on
in the a plus franchises yesterday which
we will dive into in the past five
so there will be no tv recap today and i
know like the four people who watch
dallas like will be upset but
for the most part the community remains
unaffected yeah we'll try again next
week
um just last night i we actually i had
such a busy day last night and last
night i did not get home till like 10
o'clock
because we were recording redheads then
we did our post redheads dinner which
was just such a blast
and i was just wiped out i had been like
binge
reading and doing all my homework for
four days
and i was just like like i need the
night off so there was no dallas for me
i'm so sorry to report and my reasoning
is more that i just didn't want to
yeah and the new episode of the redheads
drops tomorrow it is
never too late to become a redhead ever
never ever ever
last night when we recorded she um she
dropped her next her snitch's choice oh
wow
and it seems super snitchy i know i
think i'm going to read it
some of like the snitch's choice sinich
has really like a cult following in the
redheads you know because
some of the y a stands for books are the
most popular and then others bright side
are not
but i look forward to ascension's choice
it's been a while i've actually just
read two back to back snitch's choice
she recommended it it ends with us by
colleen hoover which i read yesterday
and i know i read two days ago and then
yesterday i read another snitch colleen
hoover rack november 9th and it was
so cute like when we went to dinner i
joined the redheads for dinner and i had
five percent left and like it was
killing me not to just like finish it
but i hate to rush like reading the end
when i'm like waiting for like you know
a quote-unquote happy ending
um i won't spoil if that happened or not
but it was so good it was also a five
star
wow should i read it um no you won't
like it you would like it ends with us
okay i will add that sounds like a good
lighter
but right now i'm just in a heavy mode
and i want to stay there until i can't
know more
well um i'm really excited about today's
show because like i have so much to say
about the gen shop at all like my jaw
literally hit the floor yesterday when
that news broke and like
that's where we like spring into action
that's like for us here at the morning
choice that's like the biggest news of
the year
yeah it's up there with like honestly
kim and kanye getting divorced i kind
allegedly
kanye thing it was sort of a slow burn
but like a divorce has happened
yeah the statistics 50 that means 50
of the couples that we have ships for
our ships will sink that's the statistic
but for a housewife to be arrested on
charges such as these an episode of
american greed like literal
season documentary of what she like i'm
shook to the core and i think we should
just get right into it because i think
we should too
so without further ado it is time for
the past without further ado
where are you okay without further ado
theodora no i can't but maybe you hurt
me maybe he'll come okay
maybe he'll transition back okay okay
[Music]
dora softest boy dora please come back
to mommy dora
stay with your auntie dora i don't think
this is working dora
he's chilling hard dora theo
wanna come you wanna come to mama wanna
come and be my best friend
come on my crunchy angel man come on
don't yeah jackie let him go put your
arm i want to see if he's actually going
to leave
theo come here tell him swagging
the tail is going back to your mama come
on
no okay he likes that empty tickles okay
without further ado we just did we hit
the crunch no no
no no okay but we do have the crunchy
dinner
and now we're gonna hit you with the
crunch because without further ado it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
without
[Laughter]
today's episode is brought to you by
bruce
bruce is basically the toothbrush of the
toaster community if you don't know what
the brush is
it is the best and most affordable
electric toothbrush
on the market out there right now it's
so fabulous i've been using it for
i feel like it's like eight months now
and honestly i've seen such a difference
in the way my teeth feel my breath my
dentist even complimented me on my
brushing skills and i told her
ma'am it's all about the brush the brush
comes with six unique modes to customize
your brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks and it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
a compact
travel case but if you're charged if
you're traveling for less than four
weeks you don't need to bring the
charger which is fabulous
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
bruce will ship you new replacement
heads every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head
the design is super sleek the electric
toothbrush has a modern aesthetically
pleasing design
and it comes in trend driven seasonal
colors that looks great on your bathroom
counter
we can both attest to that jackie and i
both have the millennial pink it's like
a blush it's very elegant really matches
the rose gold accents in my bathroom
and it comes in tons of colors but i
really like that one and the magnetic
charging stand is like very elevated
sometimes i feel like first of all a lot
of electric toothbrushes charge
over 200 for toothbrush which is insane
and then they come in like this big
bulky like robotic looking stand this
one looks like it was designed by elon
musk just like so sleek so elevated
love if you want to get 15 off your
bruce toothbrush kit and your refill
plan
use the promo code toast at bruce.com
that's 15
off using promo code toast at bruush.com
check it out pretty much every toaster
on the planet has their brush now so
if you don't want to feel left out you
should just do it wake up in the morning
feeling like brushing my teeth i just
wish
my breath would get better i'm trying to
get rid of
it but nothing seems to stay the same
until the bruise
yeah okay first story waking up
in the morning thinking about gentiles
arrest
i just wish she would snap tell the
marketing
you guys first story the only story real
housewives of salt lake city's jen
shaw has been arrested charged in a
telemarketing fraud scheme
okay jen here let's just give straight
facts
then our opinions jen shaw is facing
federal charges for her alleged
involvement
in a nationwide telemarketing scheme the
reality star was arrested on tuesday
alongside stuart smith
one of her assistants who has also
appeared on the bravo series
they have both been charged with
conspiracy to commit wire fraud in
connection with telemarketing
and conspiracy to commit money
laundering quote jen shah who portrays
herself as a wealthy and successful
business person on reality television
and stuart smith who is portrayed as her
first assistant
allegedly generated and sold lead lists
of innocent individuals for other
members of their scheme to repeatedly
scam
manhattan u.s attorney audrey strauss
said in a press release
in actual reality and as alleged the
so-called business opportunities pushed
on the victims by sean smith
and their co-conspirators were just
fraudulent schemes motivated by greed to
steal victims money
now these defendants face time in prison
for their alleged crimes
so the crimes the charges are that they
victimize 10 or more persons over the
age of 55
through wire fraud and telemarketing
that carries a maximum sentence of 30
years
damn there's one count of conspiracy to
commit money laundering which carries a
maximum sentence of 20 years
wow okay so let me just walk you through
my thought process when when i broke
this news when i heard this news
so i heard it and my mind immediately
went to her being arrested
i assumed that there was a video that
was released like six months ago i guess
someone secretly recorded her in her
house
of her like physically and everybody
that was like one month ago what did i
say
six months i haven't even watched real
housewives
i don't know concept of time yeah um she
was verbally and physically like
assaulting and attacking one of her
assistants
so when i saw that she was arrested i
just assumed that it was for that like i
didn't even question it
and then i read this like whole
statement and i've honestly never been
so shocked
and so not shocked at the exact same
time like i didn't know how to describe
what i was feeling because i was like
surprised
but this just felt like it was supposed
to happen no it explained so much yeah
all of the questions about her finances
that we've had over the course of the
season no and
yeah continue sorry um and no i was
shocked that like
this is at this level like this is a
federal case this is an american greed
this is so this yeah no like textbook
american greed i watched an episode
about like a telemarketing
scam once it was like huge and it was so
upsetting like defrauding all these old
people who
don't know better right like who their
savings like just
retirement so upsetting so like to think
of the actual crime that was committed
here is like
so morally corrupt the morally corrupt
gen sha a hundred percent title of
today's episode and so
there's two facets to the story it's one
it's the crime and like this is a this
would be a big
news story regardless of whether or not
she's a real housewife agreed and then
the other part is like
they were filming they are filming she
was filming that day and she left she
got her call and she left and five
minutes later
the fbi showed up to her they were
filming and apparently like some of the
women spoke to
federal officers right so what i'm
seeing from like bravo blogs which of
course is not 100 valid but i feel like
for the most part they kind of nail it
the women are going on a trip they're in
heber right now which we've actually
been to heber in utah
um and they were flying to colorado and
they're getting ready and the women are
all together
jenna just got tipped off by someone
like maybe her lawyer that the fbi were
like literally coming to
raid her ass and she just bounced said
there was a family emergency went i
don't know where she went but she got
um went to coach shaw and then i guess
she
like surrendered herself because i saw a
video of her walking in and out of
like the county precinct or whatever
it's called yeah
looking fire not to mention well where's
mugshot also
um she had just like i saw on instagram
that she had just been in glam
right before filming for filming so
that will be crazy that they have that
on camera but i want to talk about like
what we expect bravo to do about this
well it's something similar we're
dealing with with tom and erica girardi
even though
erica is the main character on the show
and tom is like a
extra character who's going through the
legal stuff i do think we'll see
more of jen shaw's than we will erica
james you think gen chad will stay on
the show
oh you mean i mean i think that this
footage is not going to waste
no but like after this see after the
second season i've
there's a strong possibility she'll be
in jail and but
teresa went to jail and they waited for
her i don't know if they can wait 30
years
but yeah i don't think franchise will
still be honest i mean
the legal system has to do what they do
but it's going to be a very long time
and i just don't understand how now and
it's like we always say about like
cancel culture there's a
difference between committing crimes and
like saying offensive things like i
don't know how a person who has
committed crimes such as these what
she's accused of
how you don't get fired for that right
because i guess like the
the only really comparison here is
theresa giudice and now in hindsight
it's like
why did bravo choose that course of
action for teresa giudice well it was
the best thing for the show
yeah but like
she she defrauded the government which
like [ __ ] the government honestly
i don't agree with what she did but like
i'm like all right i don't understand
someone not wanting to pay their taxes
you're more sympathetic towards um
someone who defrauded the government
versus someone who
fraud ten or more elderly people you're
more sympathetic towards gen cha's
victims than you are to
teresa's victim which was the government
right but they're both wrong
morally technically they're both wrong
but i guess this like i never
questioned teresa coming back because i
didn't really feel like she hurt
anybody in her crimes and
the way it was portrayed was that it was
really joe's crimes and he forged tweets
a signature and she was a mere victim in
all this
and she kind of took the brunt of his
sentence but with this gensha thing
it's all i don't think coach shaw was a
part of it yeah and also i think
the erika jane situation sounds similar
where this is tom's legal battle
his crimes and erica is you know
associated with it
but right so erica and teresa are on a
similar
page but erica's probably not going to
jail but this is the first time
where a housewife herself has been like
the mastermind of this
like ponzi scheme or whatever it was
yeah i just i don't
know how no it makes no sense
to me if they ever
hire her for a job again
well i do think that she will definitely
be the center of season two because i
don't know how you have this footage and
you just
ethically don't use it like it's too
that's not what i'm saying
that's not what i'm saying like right
now she has a contract like she's part
of the season and yes this is
so the biggest deal ever but i think
after this like
i just it would make no sense to me and
it's inconsistent if like
other shows and cast members are being
fired for
other offenses and then a person who
like defrauded
innocent people it's really tired for
her actions yeah no like this is
obviously like salacious and like it's
crazy but when you read about what she
actually did like it's super sad
especially because literally this
morning i was reading post and toast
after dark
and some girl shared that like something
really similar happened to her mom like
she got a phone call whatever and they
drained her entire savings
yeah so it's like it's something really
real that happens to a lot of people it
is something that i think a lot of
people know
you like warn like grandparents like if
you get a call like do not give them
your information
like people are are just trusting
trusting and naive and if you get a call
saying like your car insurance
is running out like you need to make a
payment like
why wouldn't you believe that yeah
exactly if you're an older person who
doesn't understand this stuff
so most people like are aware of these
sorts of scams and it's like
it's been gen shot on the other side
it's the crazy not only
does she defraud people she then sells
the lists of the gullible
successful marks and she gets a
percentage of the next scams
success that's [ __ ] terrible honestly
i will never understand
like people who are enrapt in criminal
schemes and who decide to go on reality
television
yes well then it's like she must have
been doing this for a really long time
so you get so comfortable you almost
probably forgot you're doing anything
illegal this is just what i do for work
yeah but also it's like hiding in plain
sight yeah
yeah no that never works no it's really
it's so crazy like first of all that it
happened while they were filming and
second of all like
the level at which her um
crimes were like because for me like
what to and i could keep comparing it to
teresa because what theresa did is like
what a lot of
like rich people do they like to pay
taxes and they go to jail like it's a
common
white collar crime right yeah so
when i like i just was not expecting
like gen shot to be like a corrupt
person who like defrauds innocent people
out of their life savings like that's
just not what i saw so that like she can
have a full
chalet outfit yeah like put on this
front but now hindsight is 20 20 and
like we said it even when it was
happening like nothing about her
finances made sense at all i know but
like she's not the first housewife
whose finances didn't mean have you met
kim zolciak
that that makes more sense no it makes
no sense no
it makes more sense but then even
remember at the reunion where she talked
about how she like owns all these
success telemarketing
yes i guess she didn't lie no not at all
but we just didn't read between the
lines because we didn't know there was
anything to say but like i will always
be
that believing and or naive that like
when you tell me you run a marketing
company i'm not just going to assume
that you're
defrauding people no but i just do think
it's funny how like for the most part
the stands of real housewives of salt
lake city were so invested in mary's
finances this season like
how did she own churches and restaurants
and all these homes and it doesn't make
sense and andy kind of grilled her at
the reunion
and jen shaw just kind of like skated by
like yeah i own a marketing company
yeah very true everyone was wait like i
think if they're
yesterday if we had had a quiz who's
who's about to get like mary
you know arrested for a criminal
enterprise
just in terms of how confusing their
finances and in terms of how bravo
portrayed it to us
yeah i would say mary also um
i didn't watch watch it raven's live
last night but they're pre-recorded so
like i doubt andy said anything so i'm
just really curious if like tonight
we'll hear anything i mean this is
really the biggest real housewives news
since teresa i guess since teresa it
doesn't feel as big because salt lake
city is such a new franchise and like i
don't think they had
but this could really be the thing that
puts salt lake city on the map i do
really hope
that this behavior is not rewarded in
any way because it's beyond anything
we've ever seen it's reprehensible
is the word beyond morally
corrupt gen cha i just like
i'm shocked no it's so crazy um
we will keep you abreast of course on
all things gen shot in the coming weeks
and just if somebody calls you asking to
refill your car insurance why don't you
just call your car insurance company
directly well i get those calls all the
time
for me like i always hang up because i'm
like i don't even have a license so i
know this is
i don't have a car do you think now with
jen shaw's enterprise like going under
that maybe i'll get those calls less
like
maybe i think jen on the other line i
think jen shaw is one
of thousands of people doing this i
agree but i get so many calls like maybe
i'll get
less maybe you'll get less for sure but
it's not the end she wasn't like the end
all be
all but maybe like she maybe she'll be
like rick singer and
sing like a bird like a bird and and
give up some of the other companies that
she's worked with wow and then if i
could see a direct result like in my
inbox being less flooded that would be
exciting
i'll never forget like when me and ben
were like 21
he called me in the middle of the day
and he is freaking out he's like
having a heart attack the irs called him
and when he told me i actually knew for
a fact the irs does not call
they mail you and he had been like
before he even called me all day like
spinning about this like bill he owed
like thirty thousand dollars to the
government he didn't know how
freaking out he finally called me and
i'm like then like
the irs doesn't call they just they they
mail
that's it and he like liter like i've
never seen someone
go from so worried to so relieved in the
course of
10 seconds like it was crazy and that's
literally like what jen shaw does like
instills the fear of god in people so
they just hand over their money
yeah no the irs doesn't come and i think
everyone needs to know that the irs does
not call
they will always mail you certified mail
trust me i've gotten a couple letters
from the irs and make your panties drop
and it'll
it'll send a shiver down your spine but
they don't call yeah
so that's why i just don't pick up the
phone ever
ever unless you're facetiming me and you
remember my family yeah
don't pick up the phone the only way to
get through yeah because for the most
part like really important information
about your car
or irs it comes in the mail it does not
come
in the form of a phone call yeah i just
like i don't need to hear from people on
the phone no i don't either
well we'll keep you abreast of the
situation
it's a crazy one yeah no we will
definitely keep you abreast it's so
important to be kept abreast especially
on situations as severe as this 100
next up ariana grande is joining the
voice as a coast
coast the vote in love with voice
coasters she's joining the boy is a koi
ariana grande is joining the voice as a
coach replacing nick jonas
this is like really crazy let me tell
you why i think it's so crazy
okay one like why nick jonas leaving i'm
sure he just has a project they they
come in and out always right
you think he has a project specimen
right
this is not that's not why it's so crazy
to me i feel like this is a
huge step down for ariana grande like
i'm i'm
actually shocked that they must be
paying her like
40 million dollars like dead serious
because this is so good for the voice
and so like not good for ariana grande
i'm just shocked it's just so
like in my opinion don't come for me
beneath her
okay i can understand how you would see
that but let me argue it through a
different lens
shall i first of all i agree they're
paying her so much money she's going to
bring in a new generation of fans
but also being a judge on a talent show
especially i would say the voices
top two of the talent shows in our
country right now
yeah well actually there's america's got
talent yeah there's so many so i'd say
top two in our country makes you
once you are a judge on one of those
shows it turns you into icon legend
status you are like
a forever sort of agree like that
cemented in
i think that while yes it's kind of like
for retirees on their way down while she
is very much ascending
i think it does cement her status as an
icon which she we already know that she
is
yeah i don't think she needed this job
to cement that like i just need to put
my air pods in and listen to rain on me
to know that she's an icon no
i hear yourself you know that but like
just in the comments
of music like when you are a judge on
the voice you're with john legend kelly
clarkson blake shelton alicia keys like
the the group it's a prestigious one
see like i don't know you're saying she
probably made 40 million dollars and i
agree with you she does not stop working
she does album tour album tour and i
think like she does really well but like
this will probably be the easiest
paycheck of her life 100 like if i was a
celebrity
i well i kind of am a celebrity but
if i was like a famous singer like i
would be gunning for a red chair like
first of all i feel like it's fun to
hang out the other coaches
it's easy work and it's so much money
like i always think about
remember those years where x factor was
on and like they had demi lovato
and britney spears they had like a nice
rotation of people i remember hearing
like demi lovato got paid 25 million
dollars to do that so like it's the
easiest job and then you just get to
like tell people they're good singers or
bad singers like that's literally what i
do for free on a daily basis and i also
think that if you are a singer
who's super talented and also very
musically kind like it's a great way to
sort of showcase another side of
yourself where it's like oh i'm also
really
smart into music theory and so i think
it assuming that you have those chops
it's a great place to showcase it
yeah i also just think in the pandemic
like people are you know looking for new
ways to make money and so
i still think this is weird um but i'm
happy for the voice because this was
obviously a huge thing for them
and i'm happy that ariana grande is
making easy money
i just i don't think that these shows
are necessarily for retirees because i
wouldn't consider
pretty much any of the voice or american
idol judges to be retirees like maybe
katy perry like she's pretty much
retired from music
but i just think it's just put out an
album she did like yeah
over the summer oh i guess daisies was
pretty good okay yeah so
not it's up for retirement but it's just
for people who are kind of set
in their careers yes and also not in any
sort of negative way but people who have
reached their peak not saying they're
coming down but they're either at
their they have ascended yeah
yeah they have ascended they're not
ascending right were you ascended or
were you ascending
but see with ariana grande she just like
keeps breaking new barriers glass
ceiling what like
so it's just interesting it's kind of
like a new thing it's like ushering in a
new generation of first of all fans for
the voice
but also now potential judges for all
these shows because she just is not the
stereotypical person i would think of
i also think that she has a really funny
personality yeah and i'm sure she's
looking forward to showcasing that
and i think if she you know some
celebrities are like boring as [ __ ] and
maybe like going on a show like this
would sort of expose them is like being
sort of like nothing of the sort like
yeah i have a good voice but like what
else
so who is it now it's it's blake shelton
john legend
kelly clarkson ari that's pretty good
it's actually crazy that from the
original four blake shelton is like
pretty much the only one still there
um no he is the only one still there and
he's actually also like
the one coach who has like the most wins
under his belt yeah okay so say you're
on the voice and all four chairs turned
for you out of this panel
wow whose team are you on i'm either
going to choose kelly or ariana and i'll
that's so hard because i'm just trying
to think of like who could actually like
mentor me i don't know how it works like
if they actually mentor the people
but if i could have like one of these
singers mentor me i mean
i want to say kelly because i like love
her but i would probably say ariana
because like her vocal range like i feel
like she can actually teach me something
also like the odds of you winning
probably small
but like i feel like have you heard me
sing you and ari could become like good
friends
yeah no and actually that does happen a
lot like that was it yes
miley cyrus became really good friends
with someone one of her contestants who
ended up passing away
oh and ray lynne is really good friends
with blake shelton
and also miley became friends with um i
forgot her name but then she came on the
breath
remember who uh
i can't remember darby anne hold on
i have no recollection hold on no
disrespectful darby i just have a bad
memory no
i think you know you know what margot
hosted with me that day that makes sense
yeah hold on let me just get her name
because she was so cute
and darby walker yeah darby anne walker
darby and walker
cute so yeah like they actually do
become friends so yeah i think if i
could take like a friendship with any of
them
i don't know wouldn't it be bad to be
friends with like shelton yeah but
probably already yeah yeah yeah i think
there's all
great choices you know a grade well it's
the one you got so
it's oh good i got ariana good cause
that's one you got
[Laughter]
anyways next stories a little broadway
news two musicals that i think might
pique your interest
coming to broadway diana the musical oh
god we are beating this horse like
seth's broadway opening date after
netflix debut diana the musical about
the late princess of wales
will resume performances at the long
ether theater on december 1st
with an opening night of december 16th
that's one year and eight months after
the production's originally planned
opening of march 31st never happened
due to coronavirus i mean i guess now
that i think about it
even though i do feel like the story of
diana has been beaten to a pulp and like
if we get one more documentary like i
don't know what i'm gonna do
when it comes to the theater and diana
they both have huge gay audiences
so i actually think like this is good
for the gays yeah no i'm sure
it's gonna be a great musical it's also
weird that it's happening like in london
not broadway like a lot of shows start
out on london and then like go to
broadway
yeah but um it's just like you know it's
hitting a little close to home
no but it's on broadway it is on
broadway in america
yeah i thought you said london did i say
london no
i don't think so okay because that makes
more sense because americans are like
infatuated with diana
yeah so i mean
that'll just be exciting that like
broadway's happening again that is true
and i i don't like i don't go to
broadway shows so i'm not even gonna say
like maybe i'll see it oh i go to a few
broadway shows like when i feel it's
necessary and then every couple years i
have to just re-see
wicked i saw it most recently with
jessica vosk she was
stellar um i definitely won't be seeing
this but i wish all the actors the best
of luck
break a leg and then also a little more
broadway news game of thrones prequel
play is in the works for broadway
huh is there also a prequel show in the
works for hbo right
uh yeah there's several there are
several spin-off shows in the works at
hbo but
also george r.r martin like literally
yesterday just signed a bigger deal with
hbo to produce like eight more shows
love to see it the play will be a
prequel story reportedly centered around
the great
tourney at harrenhal which took place 16
years before the events of game and
throws
harrenhal's mad spooky yeah um
so what's paranormal i think harrenhal
was where arya went
when she was on her way back to the
north and it was like um
like the port town like the boat town no
it was like
it was almost like a prison there and
that was where she served
tywin oh yeah was that that casserly
rock
no that was we never went to casterly
rock the lannisters never went
back really isn't that where though like
spoiler alert
peter dinklage killed his dad castle
rock captain and um
that was in regular king's landing
king's landing yeah
harren hall i really miss our game of
thrones recaps i miss them
so much they're in the bubbles the one
that was like half
burned down from like the dragon oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it was kind of
like
a ghost spooky super super spooky but i
guess 16 years ago it wasn't burned down
that's why it's probably like a bustling
metropolis no it
probably was burned down because the
dragons were from so long ago
so i guess we'll have to see but they
had attorney and like now they're
getting
attorney yeah it can't say torny no i
know
that attorney and now they'll be on
broadway i really um
like i miss our game of thrones recaps
like so desperately
maybe we should start another podcast
where we watch game of thrones from the
beginning
and recap it sounds like a lot of work i
know but i miss game of thrones
me too i'm gonna rewatch it at some
point
yeah lady so good
so good except re-watching it will make
you hate sansa those first few seasons
like with the joffrey sons of it all
like
could not stand sophie turner's
character she did end up okay but like
she just got a free pass when she was
literally the whoa of [ __ ] game of
thrones
but she she endured a lot she endured a
lot it literally took five years to get
over like the betrayal of sansa
yeah like what she did the familial
betrayal yeah
so upsetting so upsetting okay well
that's the broadway news and
i look forward to broadway coming back
and
we'll have a tiny the musical
are you ready for our next story sure
chrissy teigen grace is the cover of
people's most beautiful issue
also the beautiful issue is here and
chrissy segan's on the cover
with her kids she said i've learned how
strong i am
i mean that's chrissy that's beautiful
yeah i'm like
getting a little chrissy fatigued like
recently i go in and out because i
really feel like
sometimes when i feel like christy t
tegan has been being annoying it's just
like
the media making her annoying and it's
like she didn't actually do anything but
now i just feel like i'm being inundated
with a lot of chrissy news
and it's like always so mundane it's
literally chrissy's mindless news
and i'm just like kind of over it but
the beautiful issue is like you know
it's the biggest issue it's a big deal
and it's
she's stunning so she's stunning
beautiful stunning and smart
yeah and she has her kids on the cover
it's cute it's cute yeah we should start
a magazine
and we should have the beautiful
stunning and smart issue yes every week
and us yeah oh look no one week it's me
and it's like oh i wonder who it'll be
next week oh it's jackie
wonder who will be next week
um so christy's beautiful and that's
what you need to know
and people think so too yeah i have this
is like a nothing burger no i know but
it's like
people care about these things yeah they
care more about like sexiest man
and that's like and that's on them and
that's not misogyny and that's
misogyny like we talk about sex these
man alive we need to talk about most
beautiful yeah but like i think they're
like it's so clear that um people
magazine is trying to be like
politically correct because the men's
issue is sexiest man alive
it's a beautiful issue for women you
know like yeah no but i actually think
like
i don't know if that's politically
correct like no it's like we should be
treated equal like sexist woman alive
but it's like objectified it's true it's
like a minefield of like
of misogyny like well we're too sexy but
we're not saying they're sexy enough oh
but they're not the same it has to be
sexy yeah like it's very confusing so
i guess this is what they landed on yeah
um i had been thinking about chrissy and
chris's clean
clean cleans company okay why i just
like i saw an ad for it yesterday
and i'm just like wondering is it
outgoing yeah
and i saw an ad for it like on a bus oh
marketing dollars
yeah not a bus a bus station
bus stop yes bus station you know like
they make them nice now with the whole
it's about tv it's a bus stop it's a bus
stop yeah bus station is like you know
you're getting out of your small town
authority yeah right yes okay
i'm sure they do have hats for it at
port authority too 100
hey um nope so they're really going big
with like it's not just like we send
pr packages to chris's kids it's like
right now they're going balls to the
wall
mta yeah no they're like getting in good
housekeeping and [ __ ] you know
yeah no and i think that like it's a
good idea for a company and
i hope that it's prosperous yeah me too
more money for the kardashians
less for me are you ready for a fifth
and final story
already yeah it's a little travel news
ooh a little travel news
goodbye empty middle seats delta is
selling the whole plane starting on may
1st
i was really hoping this was going to be
a lasting change i know i do feel like
excited though that like that is a
signal that we're transitioning out of
the pandemic like
i i know things are different like you
can feel it in new york there's traffic
like restaurants are open clubs are open
this weekend
you know like not one club is actually
opening we just learned like we tried to
make a plan to go to a club this weekend
but like none of the clubs are opening
because like who can actually profit
they can't operate like what isn't he
doing but whatever so
like it definitely feels like we're out
of this we're almost there
um and so this is just like another like
flag like we're still almost out
but of course i do wish that they were
never selling middle seats again of
course but they have the seats and
they're going to sell them and
if we've learned anything um over the
last year it's like airline greed is so
real i just have to say
and they had to shelf their greed for a
whole last year so you know they're
going to come it's killing them
bigger and greedier than ever yeah
that's what actually tpg said i did a
patreon episode with him like a few
weeks ago
and i was telling him how like it's such
a delight to travel now without all
these restrictions without change fees
um and he was like yeah and i'm like do
you think that like the change he will
come back he said
the change fee is not gonna come back
because the airline said like they're
gone forever
but they're gonna come back in like
different fees like dressed in new
clothing like you know like
it's like not a change fee it's like a
flange fee you know what i mean
it's like that meme of like one person
trying wigs like trying to make a new
account since
the change be coming for you yeah
literally so like that's why
it's been such a delight for people to
travel in like the last month or two
because it's like so unique and like
this will never happen again i do have
to say though i've traveled like
not if not a lot of times i've maybe
been on a plane like
like two three times in the last year
and i flew
delta and united and both times i saw
them all having middle seats like
completely sold so i just wanted to put
that out there oh okay
i've actually been on a lot of planes
this year loki look at me
um hey look at me and delta
i've always seen does not sell that
middle seat but then
other airlines american sells the whole
ass plane
um and yes it has been it's been nicer
to travel but
it's also been like fraught with other
anxiety yeah of course so
i don't know which one i would prefer
but you remember last year when like all
this stuff was happening with the
airlines and we thought there was gonna
be like such a major change like in the
way we sit remember how like
there were all those diagrams being sent
around like airlines no longer doing
three rows uh two rows of three but they
were going to have you know two people
sitting beside each other yeah like that
what happened to that
where was the ingenuity i agree they
lost their engineering i understand
things need to change back from like how
they are now but that doesn't mean they
have to go back to how they how bad they
were how bad they were
like we're surprised there was a global
epidemic that killed hundreds of
thousands of people have you ever seen
the way we travel like of course
we're literally sitting on top of each
other for 11 hours
like of course this happened maybe we
should now learn and like
i don't know give people like a little
bit more space to sleep on an 11 hour
flight maybe
maybe so i this this story was actually
reminding me of a year ago when like
every story like we would have every day
where it's like something closed and
like the nba is not and now disneyland's
closed and so now it's like
these sorts of stories about like things
changing back to open it's like
extremely slow but it's
better than nothing i also was recently
thinking about that guy from the nba
like who touched all the microphones
like as a joke remember that and that's
why they shut down the nba
is that that's not why they shut down
yes because he tested positive and he
touched all the microphones as a joke on
his way out of a press conference
and he literally tested positive that
night but that was just like an aside
they were
they were already not playing games
because of the current virus
no no i'm literally 100 sure that i
think his name is rudy like that's why
they shut it down
i don't that's all the reporters and all
the teams two teams like
they had to shut it down okay that's not
how you might be right but that's just
not how i remember it i just remember it
was like
i think we're jillian rudy did that he
did that [ __ ]
but the nba shut down regardless of rudy
because like there's a pandemic no i
think like that was the cat they were
the cattle rudy was a catalyst
like to the whole thing you know what
i'm sure someone's gonna let us let us
know multiple people
um okay so it's wednesday we're gonna do
deer toasters which is our advice
segment and deer toasters is brought to
you
by new x cbd new x's mission is to
provide their customers with the highest
quality products at a reasonable price
with years of experience in sourcing
manufacturing and developing cbd
their goal is to make cbd accessible to
the masses they never sacrifice quality
and all of their products are natural
pure and tested so they have a couple
products that i'd like to highlight
my personal favorite is the gummies they
taste great it's their best seller
they have 15 milligrams of broad
spectrum cbd per gummy
they're vegan and made with all the best
natural ingredients so that includes no
artificial flavors
colors sweeteners and they're thc free
they're usa grown hemp and they are lab
tested so it's perfect for someone
who's like trying to ease into cbd i
take a gummy pretty much every night
um it's a fun way of taking it they
taste delicious and
if you get a consistent dose every time
which is really hard i've tried a lot of
cbd companies and with the gummies it's
like they're not
dosed evenly and it's really confusing
um so these ones are 9.99 which is a
really good price
and it's a consistent dose every time
they also have a ton of other products
and if you want to go to their website
it's
new xnu-x.com you could purchase some of
their great
products and you can use the discount
code toast for twenty percent off for a
limited time
again that's nu dash x dot com
use code toast for 20 off they have an
entire on the go collection that offers
all products under a 10
price point which is perfect for those
trying out cbd for the first time
so that's nu x dot com code toast for 20
off love it let's go dear toasters is
our advice segment if you ever want to
write in
we can do it completely anonymously you
can write in about anything in your life
that you're going through
and the email is dear toasters gmail.com
hello jackie and claudium hi i've
officially been a toaster for one year
now and i'm so thankful for the joy that
toast has brought into my life welcome
my boyfriend and i have been together
for about four years
we are very serious and close with each
other's families and have always been
before i even knew who he was he was in
a very toxic on and off long-term
relationship with a different girl
a little backstory when he and i first
started dating she was still very crazy
and tried to create problems with us
eventually she left us alone and one day
even followed me on instagram i thought
it was weird
but tried to see it as an olive branch
for the trouble she had caused so i
followed her back and i've been
following her ever since
since following her i noticed my
boyfriend's mom oh no
also follows her not a huge deal i get
that they dated for a while before i
came into the picture
this girl also has a new boyfriend now
and i noticed that my boyfriend's mom
kind of
literally likes all the photos of her
photos except the one where she's with
her boyfriend
so are you following yeah yeah kind of
strange right recently his ex
has also started a business venture come
to find out my boyfriend's mom follows
the page on instagram and likes the
facebook page
the business is literally a few months
old so she obviously went out of her way
to do this
the issue is i'm not very good at
internalizing my feelings this bothers
me
so much because where is what are his
mom's intentions it makes me feel as
though she likes her so much and wishes
her son was still with her
and that's why she's still so involved
in her life this is only stuff i can see
so like is she close with her in other
ways
my question is do i just have to live
with this and try not to overthink do i
mention it to my boyfriend he doesn't
follow her and hardly uses social media
anyway anyways
this seriously eats away at me every
time i see my boyfriend's mom
and 232 others like this photo please
help sincerely a jealous toaster
this is weird because like it's nothing
but it's also something yeah and i want
to be like you should just tell your
boyfriend like that you know this
bothers you and like
do you think that it means something but
then you also like look sort of crazy
like stop
his ex-girlfriend's facebook business
page like not even that the likes
but i'm not saying you're crazy but it
could look no you're on to something for
sure
a hundred percent question the mom
obviously like lives for the
ex-girlfriend
i have a question for toaster okay does
the mom like all of your photos do you
have a
business or something that you're
passionate about that the mom likes and
follows on facebook like
maybe it's just you know like moms are
really active you're right about that
super active just like wanting to
support some people like
i mean i i imagine
just like follow people that they know
and then like every single photo on
their
feed like that come through so like it
could be
benign but it could be not no you're
right we have to take into the fact that
this is someone's mom
it changes and like adult behaviors on
social media are just different from
ours they're not to be trusted like and
it's not malicious like it's literally
just like active active postponement
i know you i know that face like yeah so
it doesn't mean as much and it doesn't
like carry the weight that it carries
for us
so i would just my question to you is
does she like all of your photos like so
passionately and vigorously
what are her social media patterns what
other businesses does she like on
facebook is it all of her
acquaintances people she's ever met
their endeavors like is she just a
supportive
mom like look at other is it
just is she giving this girl special
treatment or is this how she treats
every right joe schmo is this a pattern
it's a good question and one worth
pursuing so best of luck to you
once you have the answer to that you
will know whether or not it's benign
or serious and if it's serious talk to
your boyfriend you know you guys
even though you might look a little
crazy like you transparency is key i
agree but just try not to like you know
be so crazy yeah yeah like try and say
it in a way that's like
not crazy hi claudia and jackie how you
doing
good my mom my mom and i are obsessed
with the podcast and we listen
every day i need some serious advice my
best friend and i have been best friends
for over
a little a little over seven years over
the past few months her brother who's
six years older than me
we have developed a romantic
relationship i have a very close
relationship with her family and he and
i are both nervous that they will not be
supportive of our relationship so we've
had to keep it a secret and have both
been sneaking around it's safe to say
i'm in love with him and he is
everything of the sort
additionally his sister my best friend
has become unhealthy obsessed with me
recently and
constantly needs my attention and
validation some days i've even gotten 10
calls from her and i could get constant
text messages
it has gotten to the point that if i
don't answer she will ask if i hate her
or question my loyalty to our friendship
she gets upset when i hang out with our
other friends without her and thinks her
friendship means less because of my
other relationships
i love her to death and never think
about ending my friendship with her i
just don't know how to approach the
situation
please help me with these two problems
one telling my best friend and her
family about my relationship with her
brother
and two how do i approach telling her i
need to have some personal space and
that our friendship is stable
and i can maintain a relationship with
her while having relationships with
others
hope to hear from you well by the way
it's very clear that like
since becoming in a relationship like
you maybe have pulled back from the
relationship with the friend
and that's why she's like having anxiety
so maybe if she knew like that you've
just been like holding the secret and
it's been like killing you
one you could kill two birds with one
stone yeah i do think that they're
linked to these two problems interesting
i hadn't thought of it like that but i
do think that you're right i think if
you come forward she'll understand why
maybe you've been more absent and i also
feel like
it will solve two issues one she'll have
a better understanding that you still
want to be her friend forever nothing
has changed
but also like it might have her back off
a little bit if like you're
now dating her brother like in a in a
positive way you'll be become sisters
i think that you should come right
exactly i think you should come forward
with it but obviously of course like now
you have to marry the brother otherwise
you've just ruined everything oh that's
the thing like
talk to the brother first like before
you blow this up be like we're getting
married right
like you know like no just make sure
you're both like actually serious
because this
is like it's in the end it's great but
it will be like awkward for a little
while
so just make sure that like you're both
on the same page in terms of this
relationship like we are otp correct
if everything works out like this is
amazing your best friend became your
sister you guys just got even closer
than she even wanted like you have a man
and he's everything of the sort like
we'd love to see it um
if this is just a fling like you've lost
your boyfriend you lost your best friend
if this is a feeling like get the like
fling yourself out of it like it's so
not worth it
oh also um okay come clean because also
the longer you keep a secret like
the more hurtful and then they're like
it's not about the secrets i didn't tell
you it's not about like no page it's
about the secret yeah right of course
okay it's always about to say that
question for you
what what if it's not a fling but like
they don't wind up getting married like
they're together for like four years and
then they break up terrible
terrible yeah you should have known yeah
but like that's not a reason not to
pursue a relationship i hate when people
do that like
your best friend is my sister like what
just [ __ ] like
live life yeah but definitely like it
requires a little more caution because
there's more at stake but you still need
to follow your heart
just be communicative like make sure to
talk to the boyfriend first be like
before we [ __ ] come clean like i'm
serious about this are you cause yeah
like i'm not gonna blow up my
relationship with your sister and your
whole family
just so you can change your mind in a
month no when it's like we're boyfriend
and girlfriend like we're exclusive like
make sure
like all the things the key points like
we're moving in the right direction
maybe like have some hard conversations
that you maybe would have had later but
just to like make sure you guys you know
there's so much going on here but i
can't stress enough how important this
particular conversation
is because like it's the key to the
whole thing yeah it's the foundation in
which like your plan is built on so
talk to the boyfriend first yeah just
like make sure you guys are like relying
on how you want to raise kids like blah
blah
blah
parenting style so nothing comes up down
the road that would like ruin everything
yeah yeah it's like in this book i read
um okay dear jackson claude this is our
final one this is gonna sound crazy but
i think something is up with my
boyfriend and his sister-in-law oh my
this is also like the book i just read
okay
a little backstory yeah now you sound
like me that's just like in this book i
just heard i know claudia
okay a little backstory the
sister-in-law is married to my
boyfriend's older brother
she's the same age as my boyfriend and
they went through elementary middle and
high school together
my sister-in-law is married to my
boyfriend's older brother so it's two
brothers
she's the girlfriend of the younger and
the older brother has a sister
has a wife they've been
so the sister-in-law and her boyfriend
husband no and the boyfriend have are
the same age and they went to elementary
middle and high school together i met
her
before i met her my boyfriend would talk
so much [ __ ] about her how she's messy
leaves garbage all over her car
doesn't work etc
it's just like so mean she doesn't work
like these carvings all over her car
like those are some of the worst things
that you can think about someone yeah
about another bird
and that's also like just don't leave
garbage all over your heart because like
that's just never how you want to meet
described that's how you want to be
remembered
okay so i go out of town to meet his
family things seem normal until we meet
the family at the brother and
sister-in-law's house
are you okay okay i go out of town it's
so confusing
and it's also hard for me to move on
like from one crime tree to another okay
i go out of town to meet his family
things seem normal until we meet the
family at the brother and
sister-in-law's house
the brother is in and out of the picture
because his job requires him to leave
town a lot
after a few beers i'm sitting talking to
the family i noticed my boyfriend just
getting like weird uncomfortable almost
side note we have been together since
august but moved in together within four
months quarantine makes people crazy
then we leave and we're all we're
hugging everyone goodbye and it was so
[ __ ] awkward between them
i felt like there was this weird vibe
you know when you just feel it the
sister-in-law is a total opposite of me
imagine i am megan
fox she is the mousy amanda seyfried
character in jennifer's body
i could tell she's thinking who the [ __ ]
are you this whole time while talking to
me
a few weeks later the sister-in-law's
following me on every single social
media platform
weird as weird as we didn't hit it off
then my boyfriend posted me in a story
she replied fire emoji
and i tried to be funny and scroll up in
his dms because the bubble looked big
he didn't let me and closed out of his
app hella quick
now he's now he's not talking that much
[ __ ] about her and i just can't shake
the feeling that something is up
help i fully understand that i should
just be up front and ask him i'm an
adult and i know
and i know this but is there any other
option signed my boyfriend may be in
love with his sister-in-law
so i'm inclined to like tell you that
you're crazy but there is something
about a woman's intuition like sometimes
when you get a gut like you just like
need to follow it
i agree but it also doesn't sound like
your boyfriend's gonna be super
forthcoming because like he didn't let
you read the messages unless he's like
working on the proposal
with your sister but they've they've
only been together since august but they
moved quickly
quarantine makes crazy things happen um
so like there's a chance that like he
wants to hide something you know like
it's a surprise for you
in his in the dms it's i don't think
they're like
sexting in the dms you need to
get your monocle out and do a little
workout
oh okay yeah the little eye and do a
little spy work i think keep your
concerns to yourself until you have
something to bring to him otherwise
you look crazy and he'll cover his trail
better and you just sound like a
conspiracy theorist you're right you
need proof
and then he starts to like and then he's
like oh she's clogged like let me
cover up my twitter so do better
so i would say
keep a close close eye nothing to see
here yet
but get get to work on the detected
front
yeah that's probably the best advice i
can't do any better like until you have
proof like keep it to yourself keep your
cards close to your chest
and just snoop because right now he
doesn't know that you're on to him so
that's like the best type of way to
attack you know yep trust your gut
but get some concrete proof as well
trust the proof yeah
well good luck with that and thank you
to everyone who wrote into your toasters
a reminder if you ever want to write
into our email is dear toasters
gmail.com
we always keep it anonymous and you can
write in about anything from
sister-in-law did your boyfriend
accidentally jizz in a cup
it's all up there and so just also if we
if you owe us an update please send us
an update we've had so many good ones in
the last few weeks and we want to hear
from you guys so let us know what
happened if
you wrote in and we read it on air yeah
i think that's it and i think that's all
she wrote thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart rated cat box all the places
wherever we listen to podcasts fine this
morning just leave a five-star review
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are
hope you have an amazing hump day don't
forget to hump someone you love make it
through today and then we're on the
other
side of this week so just keep your eyes
closed and persevere yes
[Music]
goodbye